the only thing they can be short of
about the future is it'll be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
professor John Eric goth a
world-renowned sports physics researcher
known for his work on world cup soccer
balls and Tour de France modeling works
with students at the University of
Lynchburg to understand how the laws of
physics may be applied to crop Maga Krav
Maga is a self-defense and fighting
system that also borrows from various
other disciplines Rob Maga combines
realistic fight training and is known
for its efficiency in real-world
situations
professor Goff's research uses the idea
that we are all constrained by the laws
of physics according to his
investigations it's possible to apply
some of the same physics principles that
are used to understand atoms and the
cosmos - the moves and Krav Maga in his
second book Professor gob connects the
ideas behind advances in technique to
evolution by natural selection
professor gongs book is free of
equations and instead focuses on
intuitive physics anyone can learn from
his book even though is with a fear of
math the physics of Krav Maga by John
Eric Goff is available now and it's my
great honor to be speaking to John Eric
Goff who is the author of this wonderful
new book called the physics of Krav Maga
and we will get into what is Krav Maga
and why are we talking about it into the
impossible but let me first introduce
John John is a professor and the chair
of the physics department at the
University of Lynchburg in Virginia he's
the author of gold medal physics the
science of sports and he holds a black
belt in karate and a purple belt in Krav
Maga
now John first for our listeners may be
wondering why are we talking about this
strange Hebrew words called Krav Maga
can you explain what is Krav Maga and
why is it of possible interest to anyone
in science so Krav Maga is one of the
fastest-growing martial arts systems in
the US I think people are starting to
notice the occasional billboard now with
a kromagg advertisement and in Hebrew it
means [ __ ] contact combat
the idea is to combine many different
disciplines from boxing to other forms
of martial arts and the system developed
in the 1930s by Licht and field who in
Bratislava was trying to get some of
these Jewish neighborhoods protected he
there were some violence going on at the
time some anti-jewish violence and it
developed out of that desire to protect
the neighborhoods and the idea is to
take several fighting techniques from
all kinds of different systems and
combine them into one really good system
that emphasizes street fighting and up
close and using offense and defense at
the same time so it's a it's a pretty
powerful system it's it's quite fun to
train in yeah so a lot more people might
be familiar with karate which you're
also a master a black belt level
practitioner of I am only a lowly a
yellow belt in Krav Maga but I also
practice it and I found it invaluable to
you know kind of maintaining a healthy
mind I think part of being having a
healthy mind is having a healthy body
and as you said there's it's a lot more
practical in some sense or focused on
tactics for actual combat which is a
little bit different than karate and you
make this distinction in your book and I
wonder if you could just explain a
little bit being such a high-level
expert in both disciplines can you talk
about what is the difference between
karate which people might be familiar
with from the movies and you know Krav
Maga which as you say is rapidly growing
in popularity but maybe less familiar to
the listeners so one of the things we do
when we train in karate is we practice
these very elegant Coty's and kata and
Japanese just means form and the
techniques are used in the Coty's
punches kicks all kinds of various spins
various techniques are used to comprise
the kampala Nakata's but the idea is to
do these things with enough repetition
and enough in sequence that you might be
able to use them in an actual fight Krav
Maga doesn't really have you doing
a bunch of Coty's during your training
it's okay it's very up close we trained
with knives with guns hostage situations
terrorist situations all kinds of pretty
scary stuff and you know it might be
considered a little bit more realistic a
little bit more real-world that's not in
any way to disparage any other martial
arts system or to you know take away
from what they could possibly provide
you in the form of self-defense but I
think the the aim and the goal of Krav
Maga is just you know hey I've only got
an hour or two a week to devote to going
to class and you know I want to start
getting into the nitty-gritty and and
learn some things that can really help
defend myself if I ever have to use it
now this book you talk about throwing
yourself into your work so you you're
depicted in the book in many many
different areas where you are seemingly
facing almost a mortal danger in fact
there's one I don't want to give a
spoiler alert it's not a typical
narrative type book but you do go in to
the very end and you talk about some
principles that are extremely you know
deadly serious actually talked about
hostage situations and this is showing
you're your teacher this is a mr.
abercrombie and he is the he's the owner
and founder of what's the name of the
studio in Lynchburg that you guys will
click lifted Abercrombie's my instructor
he's one incredible instructor he's he's
a you know I I can't give him a loud
enough shout out his warrior Success
Academy is in Forrest Virginia so anyone
in in Lynchburg Forest area of Virginia
would do themselves a great great help
to go and at least take a sample class
see what was what it's like and you're
gonna get hooked on mr. ever crumb
yeah and the as I say you really get
into this to the practice and explain in
physical techniques that really you make
use of the laws of Newtonian mechanics I
mean you don't need to know quantum
field theory to understand this book you
actually don't even need to know any
math or any beyond division perhaps and
multiplication and even there it's so
digestible and accessible
I think even somebody without even high
school physics can understand it
certainly the members in the studio I
trained at Krav Maga do this style of
Krav Maga called Krav Maga worldwide and
have a shout-out to my teacher Mike
Malaga at at the MMA academy in San
Diego and he is also a master
practitioner many level black belt and
the thing that I always take away is how
serious they take it but they make it
they also make it fun and they make it
and it's an enjoyable exercise it
doesn't have to be about deadly you know
deadly arts and saving your life but it
can and that's what's so important for
those of us with kids I'm sure in your
studio and mr. abercrombie studio they
also have classes for children and to
avoid you know all these awful things we
hear about and at least at MMA academy
there are classes for kids to avoid
escape evade etc some of the you know
some of the situations that
unfortunately become modern reality my
two wonderful daughters Emily and Abby
got me interested in karate back in 2012
and that's when I first met my my
instructor and a year later he started
these Krav Maga classes and they were
held at night and they were only for
adults I think the idea was the karate
classes gave more opportunity to learn
some life skills you know there would be
a monthly skill and for example
integrity or you know building up your
confidence or respecting people or
honesty you know these these types of
skills that would come out in the
training as well as being talked about
directly the evening classes where we're
using things like guns and knives and
hostage situations that you know I don't
know that it was necessarily we trying
to avoid scaring the kids but you know
we're trying to be a little bit more
realistic and you know maybe the
language might pop out from time to time
to make it even more realistic but try
to get the the situation where we're
training in an environment where we feel
a little bit of stress and I think that
worked better without the younger kids
but certainly any any
you know teenagers probably 16 or older
ethic could easily take a Krav Maga
class yeah yeah it's about we talk a lot
about maintaining situational awareness
when you go from different region spaces
at school transitional spaces into cars
at the shopping center nowadays most
kids are even more you know kind of
distracted by technology we have our
earphones on we take off your shoes and
you're really not as focused on the
situation your surroundings and I think
just even taking the classes has made me
much more aware you know you go to a
parking lot before you get out of the
car look around you know assess your
surroundings don't put in your earphones
don't just look around not not to be
paranoid but you know the way that you
look for different exit routes and you
have a plan and that's what Krav Maga
you know the motto is get home safely
and I feel like your book you know for
for as sort of a vector you know to use
the physics or biological and now that
it gets people interested into possible
techniques that could save their life
but they may not be aware of how many
physical principles they're employing as
they do that and as I say in the you
throw yourself so commendably into the
work and do stuff that I can't only you
know I can't envision personally doing
for my book you know I had to go to the
South Pole or whatever but but I didn't
have to get punched in the face and you
know here's a picture of oh yeah have
razor golf getting you know getting his
claw there's a there's a cute story
about that picture because the lady
who's touching me is a colleague of mine
al dr. Fuhrman who actually was a former
student of mine so probably had a chance
to take out a little frustration on an
old grade or something that maybe she
didn't like but yeah I mean I was very
curious to know what the headgear would
provide in the foreign perfection what
kind of acceleration my head would feel
and it felt about four G's worth of
acceleration and you know that's not
quite to the level of you know what you
get is a concussion risk but you know
it's enough to ring your bell a little
bit and yeah and stun you and you know
and I do want to pick up on something
you said earlier about not having you
know equations and things
that in the book even an instructor of
Krav Maga is likely talking to students
who even if they're passionate about it
a couple times a week you know they've
got jobs and other careers and Families
and this kind of thing and the
instructor realizes that the student is
not likely to have the same level of
passion and commitment time to devote as
the instructor is and you know I mean I
feel the same way as it is a university
teacher when my students are working on
physics problems and that kind of thing
or doing research with me the idea is
they're not all going to become you know
university professors are not going to
devote their lives and into physics so
when you're teaching something like
physics or teaching Krav Maga and you
have to have a mindset that you want to
provide somebody something very helpful
in a half hour hour whatever you know
you got them and not expecting to go off
and have the same love and passion that
you can do for the field so the really
good instructors and you know my
instructors will I mean he's got
multiple black belts and all kinds of
different disciplines
you know from Aikido and a karate and in
Krav Maga I mean you know you he's very
dedicated to martial arts and in trains
in multiple fields but he can take
somebody who's you know middle aged out
of shape not very flexible and start
doing things that you start gaining a
little bit of confidence that's right
and and that's the that's the idea
behind teaching some physics principles
in the book is I want to stay
qualitative and I want to stay
conceptual and I want to rely on
something that I think is important
which is intuitive physics right and
even if somebody's never heard of a
differential equation or you know
Newton's second law or you know if you
really want to get into quantum
mechanics and start talking about the
Dirac equation and all kinds of
interesting things that I love to play
with if they don't have any of that
training or background they're used to
getting you know at some point in their
life they've fallen down I mean they
know what happens when their balance is
disrupted they know what happens when
they spin around they might get a little
dizzy they might get a little
disoriented so they
already have a lot of intuition just
growing up in an environment that humans
have have all didn't and that's a
powerful thing to use as a starting
point for teaching yeah you give a
really nice kind of analogues where you
you you know encourage the reader to
sort of play along with you in one case
you're talking about you know what is a
hard core power I mean everybody here's
what horsepower is but not too many
people have great appreciation as a
horse
isn't that something to do with you know
some animal and like what does that have
to do with me you get this example of
going up a flight of stairs with your
way carrying a certain amount of mass
and how quickly that's done and it's
extremely intuitive and and I think
that's that's the thing that I want to
get to it just to turn to now it's
really how do the lessons learn from
this book how can we translate them into
real-world situations not necessarily as
I said it has an intrinsic value for a
life-and-death situation awareness etc
but you mentioned a keyword which is
confidence and I feel like a lot of our
students don't they don't take care of
their bodies as well as they take care
of their minds and and it's hard in
college to make the time you know with
all the social pressures with all the
commitments activities etc plus classes
to really have to take care of your body
but I think any kind of sport or martial
art especially you know my daughter's
you I know you have daughters and and
getting them into ways to just be aware
confident and and I think that
translates as I think Aristotle said you
know in the ancient physicists a sound
mind is a sound body and and having you
know our sound body leads to a sound
mind and I think they're sort of that
that nature I think can inspire people
and so I do see this as a as a vector to
to teaching people through something
intuitive that all you need is the book
in your body and you can learn these
concepts that are relatively abstract
unless you go to a physics lab and roll
balls down inclined planes or what have
you so I think I definitely want to
commend you on that I do want to ask you
so you said it was your colleague who
was punching you in the face here did
did she ever get tenure just curious
it's coming in a couple years okay well
yeah okay well I wish your luck I can't
wait to see what she'll do to you after
she gets after she gets tenure your next
book it's funny you know the great the
great sage Mike Tyson said everybody has
a plan until they get punched in the
face now I mean when you have
experienced these kinds of situations
where the stress level as you say has
amped up have you noticed any
translation through into your your day
job which is you know the chairman of a
department is an extremely stressful job
where you've got to work on all the
elements that come into play is you talk
about in the book it's not just being a
good striker a fighter it's also being a
good a good assistant and helping people
train because we all have to hold for
people we have to practice have you
found any of the skills that are
integral to Krav Maga translate into
your day job sure I mean you know one of
the well I mean let me back up a
cigarette I think if you think about the
way we learn things and setting aside
multiple paragraphs of neuroscience that
we will avoid right now there really are
two ways that we learn things you're
either gonna fill a hole in your brain
that represents ignorance or you've got
something wrong and you want to correct
it and the questions or the comments
that you want to get people to say what
they're talking about science or
training in martial arts or anything is
I don't know or I am wrong right and it
it has its genesis in honesty and if if
you're confident enough to be wrong and
to admit you're wrong that opens the
door wide open to learning something and
if you say I don't know something I'm in
right about something
well now you can fill that void with a
lot of information you can go out and
test things yourself so when you're
talking about all the different things
that we teach in a you know physics
setting you know when I'm working with
my research students and we're modeling
the Tour de France every year we're
working on testing for the World Cup
soccer balls that we do
for you know the balls that were used in
in Russia recently and then back in in
Brazil the the teamwork and the the
humbleness that comes from saying I
don't really understand how this works
and I want to figure it out I want to
discover something and then you take
that into the you know the classroom and
you're your instructor or there is
trying to teach you something and you
say you know I don't really understand
this I'm going to hold up my hand and
get it my money's worth and say you know
we need to go through this again and you
do the same thing in class where you
could do the same thing at a board
meeting I mean you do the same thing
interacting with colleagues or working
in teamwork if you can provide something
to the team that's beneficial and
helpful and then somebody else says you
know I don't understand you have a
little more respect for that person
because that person was listening to you
didn't quite follow what you had to say
had the nerve and confidence to say I
don't yeah I'm like I don't care if
people think I'm ignorant about
something or I didn't get something I'm
gonna better myself and try to improve
and of my understanding and and you
really develop respect for people who do
that yeah absolutely and I feel like you
know these these skills translate so
well and and and again thank you for
this wonderful book that that will
undoubtedly influence people to if not
explore Krav Maga
per se but to seek out ways to to
develop these these tools and and and
just really as you say fill in these
lacunae in their and their in their own
development and that will translate I
always say that's the one force that's
really difficult to measure it's a
leverage I mean you leverage these
skills into the classroom into the into
the faculty meetings into a board
meeting if you're an entrepreneur we
have a lot of listeners out there who do
venture capital who do you know do drug
development things completely different
from Krav Maga or physics and you know
as I was reading your book I felt like
there were so many lessons that could
actually form the basis of a self-help
book or or surprisingly really translate
far beyond the
the world of physics but in particular
to physics so you know for example
there's you know there's there's topics
that I just highlighted in the book
about you know fitness so again
enhancing your fitness will lead to a
more sound mind I think as well having
balance both maintaining your own
balance and as you talked about you know
like getting up after you fall down
things like that resiliency and teaching
people this the skill of you know you
get knocked down if you expect it you
know as Mike Tyson said as I said if you
have a plan and so you get punched in
the face well what do you do after that
now you have a plan right or now your
plan has changed so how do you implement
that you're a contractor construction
worker you know things change and that's
part of what I say my job is and I'm not
a chairman of the department I don't
have that particular brand of masochism
and I think it takes to to be a chairman
but but anyway you know what once once
we get into our jobs I really feel like
part of our job is being a fireman or
fire well you know putting out these
fires and anticipating and kind of
what's going to happen in the future and
you know I think one one lesson that you
know even though about you know most of
the book is about Krav Maga per se there
are these lessons that can translate
into students in particular
undergraduates and including things like
cooperation which you wouldn't think you
know these guys you know beating each
other up like are they cooperating yes
they are right these are they're
actually cooperating aren't they so yeah
I mean cooperation is definitely part of
it I mean you know this where we grew up
as predators our species did sore eyes
or forward-facing and it's nice if you
had someone that you know kind of look
behind you and kind of have your back if
you're ever in a bad situation you know
so that definitely these skills that
we're talking about in a Krav Maga class
where you're trying to problem-solve you
know someone's coming at you with with a
knife or you're stuck between cars or
whatever it is you've got a problem to
solve and you got to do it quickly and
if you are used to solving problems
whether it's in a business setting or
a physic setting you're you're trained
in tossing out superfluous information
you know I don't care that the cars pink
you know I mean you know there are
certain details you might have in your
mind but you start realizing you know
what I really care about is maybe that
thing can block my attacker while I'm
running away or something you know you
start strategizing your exit you start
thinking about you know well you know
this guy coming at me he's pretty buffed
and he's got a you know knife sticking
out of his pocket you know I mean my
best defense might be to just run as
fast as I can you know and in you start
assessing things very quickly like that
and trying to fight that that tendency
that I think a lot of us would have you
know to freeze mm-hmm yeah exactly so I
think it's so interesting to to see what
what are these skills you know mu skills
many skills are not transferable like I
don't think if I had you know a decade
of a painting class practice I'd ever be
able to paint something beyond a stick
figure although I did do this paint ya
know I didn't know but but but do you
think these skills in particular as we
say we they translate how hard or easy
is it to learn a martial art like Krav
Maga karate certainly it's something
could be taught the question is you know
how does a typical process work and how
does it compare to teaching and learning
physics well in in my Krav Maga class
I'm gonna see you know students in there
at various stages of their training some
of them are gonna be very new haven't
even put on a white belt yet I'm gonna
see other ones who are you know advanced
in the been doing it for years they're
gonna be much more fit they're gonna be
people who are going to be overweight
including myself you know if I let
myself go for a couple months don't get
to class enough because I'm too busy
researching or whatever I mean the thing
is there are all kinds of different body
types and people with different levels
of dedication and they're all kind of
jumping in it the you know deep into the
pool really they're you know even the
person who's just starting out maybe
it's someone's first class you know you
start on page 1 of the manual I mean you
know you're showing up and you're just
doing whatever is being taught that day
in class and it might be gun defense or
it might be an attacker with a knife or
something so the idea is to give
somebody something even if it's very
tiny that you know hey I accomplished
something in the last 45 minutes I you
know had an understanding of how you
know someone's finger can be hurt if I'm
pulling the gun a certain way and trying
to get out of the you know someone
having a gun in my head I mean just
something tiny doesn't mean you're gonna
go off after one class and be you know
the next Bruce Lee but you're gonna be
able to at least start thinking in your
mind you know okay I've got an option
now I've got something to think about if
you know you never want to be in a
harrowing situation like that but if you
ever are maybe you've got an option that
can help you and it's the same thing
that in a physics class you know I tell
my students that all the time the value
of a liberal arts education I mean
you've got to exercise your mind in many
many different ways and it goes beyond
you know physics you've got to learn you
know to communicate with people and
convey ideas and you've got to be able
to structure and organize maybe you're
setting up a meeting maybe you're
setting up a project with a you know
you're going to lead a team of employees
doing something I mean there are certain
things you got to think about maybe even
outside the box sometimes that can be
very helpful to you and very helpful to
your team absolutely yeah so speaking of
you know of students and and physics
education talk to me a little bit about
Lynchburg University Lynchburg and
around its what it's known it's known
for and what kind of what kind of
programs that you have there for a
potential perspective undergrads so we
were founded in 1903 it's been a while
not by any means the oldest of the
universities in the US but we were
Lynchburg College until the summer of
2018 and we became University of
Lynchburg our current name is University
of ledge burg Lynchburg Zin south
central Virginia a beautiful part of
Virginia
you know we've got great mountains and
what
areas and lakes and trails and all kinds
of things you can do around here and
maybe about three hours drive from the
beach so it's it's a nice place to live
and work the university itself you know
stresses of liberal arts education the
physics major that we offer is is you
know we have a small department and the
classes are small I mean we really get
to know our students and you know I take
great pride in the sports physics
research that I've been able to do here
in the last 15 years because I'm not
working with massive budgets but you
know I'm working with colleagues and in
England and Japan and now actually a
University of Vienna and a couple other
colleagues in the US and the experiences
that you can get at a small College
include you know hands-on interactions
with laboratory equipment with an
instructor who's right there with you
you're not being taught by a graduate
student and my students who do research
projects they publish with me I mean you
know I put their name first on the paper
and get them out there and really want
them to leave University of Lynchburg
well-equipped for their futures that's
phenomenal so you mentioned a little bit
about sports physics can you talk a
little bit about your previous book
which is a best-seller called the gold
medal physics the science of sports sure
so that book the genesis of that book
was that I had published a paper
modeling the Tour de France with a
student and we dad's a little bit of
success with that paper how long would
it take you to bike the Tour de France
the world's most famous cycling race is
more than 2,000 miles split over 21
stages it includes fast flat sprints and
grueling mountain climbs every year John
Eric Gough and a team of his
undergraduate students at the University
of Lynchburg predict how fast the
winning cyclist will complete each stage
they don't predict which cyclist will
win but they have developed an
impressively accurate method to forecast
the winning stage times first the team
breaks each stage down into a sequence
of incline planes creating a simplified
computer model of the races terrain the
team relies on published data for elite
cyclists and inputs several physical
factors into their model to calculate
how fast their model cyclists will
complete each stage one of these factors
is the power output of their model
cyclists who will be heavier more
aerodynamic and flat stages and lighter
more enduring in mountain stages their
model also accounts for rolling
resistance which is the friction between
the bike's tires and the road as well as
the air resistance experienced by the
cyclist and the bike their model is
incredibly precise in 2016 for example
Goff's team predicted the winning times
of four stages to less than 1% error and
14 stages to under 5% error I got a call
one day from the publisher or the editor
at Johns Hopkins University Press and we
started talking about this paper and
essentially got offered a book deal and
I never really thought about writing a
book and I thought about putting some of
these sports ideas into print and I
wanted to highlight some of the sporting
events that I loved growing up I mean I
was enthralled when you know doug flutie
through his Hail Mary to be 'miami in in
84 and yeah you know always loved Greg
Louganis who I always tell people that
you know I'm on the cover of my first
book and the cover shows Greg Louganis
going into a pool with abs that look
like you could fire a bullet into and it
wouldn't even hurt him but I'm on the
back cover of course you know so I love
DNA in 84 and 88 watching Louganis dive
and Catarina Vette skating and stuff so
a lot of these events I decided to write
about in the context of physics and
didn't hesitate from using some
equations and in some high school
mathematics I didn't go beyond algebra
trigonometry but wanted to show people
how they could take some fairly basic
physics do a little bit of mathematics
and come up with some interesting
results
this this second book I really wanted
the challenge of writing about physics
from a purely conceptual point of view
and it's not in any way to insult people
who've never really studied math or
science
- you know I'm not talking down to them
I can assure people that that the crux
they're sorry the crutch of using
mathematics is very powerful especially
when you're right out of graduate school
you can point to an equation and their
safety there because they're well obeyed
rules and and you don't have to think of
analogies and all this thing but when
you're really trying to talk to the
general public and I really tried to put
science on the sports pages in my career
you want to be able to convey you know
science is a fantastic tool for helping
us understand the world and it's not
your sports I mean it's anything you
know we have we're living longer we're
enjoying our lives more because of what
science has been able to provide us and
the idea is that you can learn just a
couple of basic ideas that that you know
the laws of physics completely constrain
all of us and when you're trying to
write purely conceptual physics and
trying to think of analogies it's not
talking down at all to anybody it's it's
trying to say I want to connect with you
in a way that shows that I care I mean
I'm trying to find something that will
relate to your life you know whether
it's tightening a lug wrench on a you
know a car or you know sitting down and
having a pint after class you know I
mean just being able to connect with
people because you know I'm no better
than anybody else just because I'm not a
physicist and you know my instructor may
not be able to play with mathematics and
the equations of physics and state
things like that but his intuitive
physics is phenomenal I mean you know he
won't have the vocabulary of a physicist
when describing a certain move but he
mean I can stay watch sometimes in awe
the ability to describe what a certain
technique is doing because all the
physics is there and I felt like when I
was writing the book I was just kind of
taking a lot of things I learned from
him and just kind of sprinkling some of
the ideas of physics just to make it a
little bit more concrete from the way a
scientist would would describe it right
but you know that's that's the goal so
was kind of the transition from the
first book to the second book that's
great I don't know well we're gonna
finish up soon I know you've got a busy
busy schedule to keep as chair any
things that you'd like to refer the
listeners to I hope that we can have you
back on maybe this summer for the Summer
Olympics we can sure Scott's called
metal physics until then any other
things you'd like to bring to the
listeners attention while we have a few
minutes remaining well certainly anybody
watching this with college-age kids
University in Lynchburg is a great place
to study it's a great place to live it's
a great place to work I am not shy at
all about telling my kids in the first
year class if you are really interested
in something and you want to get
involved in research we'll do it I mean
I've gotten kids going into research the
summer after their first year so you
know the idea is hey you may not know
all the physics you need but if you have
a passion to do something we're gonna
make that thing you know blow up I mean
we're gonna do something fantastic yeah
and you might get a chance to live out
every student's dream them punching
their professor in the face John we
might temper that a little bit that's
right maybe your next book should be the
physics of you know making pasta or
something you know a little little less
contact but but I commend you so I Leon
this wonderful book John Eric Gough
that's selling author of gold medal
physics as well as the physics of Krav
Maga can't wait to have you back on
again John thank you so much for
introducing us to your wonderful
University and to the research that you
guys are so heavily invested in thank
you so much and we hope to talk to you
again soon thank you Brian I really
enjoyed it
the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is it'll be absolutely
[Music]